[Applauso]
[Musica]
esiste un formidabile meccanismo che noi
utilizziamo nella quotidianità con
notevole disinvoltura e beneficio un
meccanismo che impariamo ad utilizzare
già quando siamo bambini la capacità di
scegliere scegliere individuare tra più
opzioni più situazioni più oggetti
quello che risulta più adatto a una
particolare circostanza o a una nostra
particolare necessità
utilizziamo questo meccanismo veramente
sempre da piccoli scegliamo i giocattoli
crescendo scegliamo vestiti scegliamo
dove andare a mangiare
scegliamo le nostre vacanze le persone
da frequentare nomi dei nostri figli
ogni cosa ogni passo è una scelta
un'attenta analisi di numerosi elementi
perché per poter compiere una scelta
ovviamente bisogna identificare più
elementi possibili affinché quello
identificato sia veramente quello più
adatto
provate a immaginare anzi e ricordate un
posto che frequentate quasi sempre una
pizzeria un ristorante conoscete bene i
profumi conoscete molto bene anche il
cameriere quale faccia che nonostante
sappiate memoria tutto il menu perdete 5
10 minuti a leggerlo quasi nel tentativo
disperato di ricercare un elemento nuovo
qualcosa che ti di che vi dia
l'opportunità di eseguire di nuovo una
scelta dedichiamo veramente tanto tempo
tante energie alle scelte in genere
rapper che quando si tratta di salute di
noi della nostra famiglia del nostro
futuro
non diamo le stesse energie non
dedichiamo la stessa attenzione
vedete sta cambiando molto il concetto
della salute non oggi però negli ultimi
vent'anni sicuramente non si punta più
solo alla quantità la qualità è
diventata fondamentale la qualità è
fatta da piccoli dettagli che sono
validi per ciascuno di noi in maniera in
maniera in misura differente se vi
dicessi che ho identificato due tre
ospedali
mia moglie deve partorire e tra questi
due tre ospedali mi soffermo su due
dettagli che così sembrano veramente
ridicoli un parcheggio è un bar aperto
24 ore perché da un lato
io so già la scelta che ho fatto perché
per lo più le scelte abbiamo fatto a
priori o due opzioni da un lato o una
nuova famiglia in cui ogni istante è
veramente irripetibile ogni momento ogni
sorriso è una cosa unica che io so già
che una volta persa ha perso e
dall'altro lato o tornare a casa
deviazioni stradali traffico poi
ritornare nel parcheggio dell'ospedale
non trovar posto fissare alla ricerca di
qualcuno con le chiavi in mano la mano
dentro la borsa chiedendo scusi va via
vedete bene che due elementi veramente
di poco conto di poc'anzi come il
parcheggio e il panino veloce per poi
tornare su risultano quasi fondamentali
o almeno lo sono sicuramente per me
quante volte vi è capitato di volervi
informale con un amico o il parente o
l'amico di un amico il quale ha avuto un
problema a volte anche di poco conto un
problema un dentro o anche un problema
molto più grande il quale ha visto è
stato visitato da un medico è andato una
struttura un ospedale dove voi volete
andare per potergli chiedere
informazioni in più oltre a quelle
classiche ospedale all'avanguardia fall
e aggiornate medico preparato perché
volete vivere la sua esperienza per
capire se effettivamente il posto giusto
per voi se io vi dicessi che un posto
così c'è un posto dove voi potete
incontrare non una due dieci venti
persone ma centinaia se non addirittura
migliaia esperienze che voi potrete
vivere in terza persona per carità pro
potete vivere
e siccome qualcuno sicuramente
rispecchierà il vostro fabbisogno fretti
in grado di compiere una scelta ben più
consapevole del solo ospedale
all'avanguardia
veramente non diamo tanta importanza ad
alcune cose siano andare a fare un
prelievo banalmente una cosa che tutti
abbiamo fatto un controllo annuale e
devo andare una clinica che
effettivamente sono veloci e rapidi ma
non ho calcolato che gli in quella
struttura in quella clinica non c'è un
servizio autobus diretto e non c'è un
parcheggio
ecco che una condivisione con struttura
nuova con molti reparti di vario tipo ma
non esiste un servizio di autobus
diretto per me è un'esperienza che
diventa fondamentale per la scelta
perché è giusto che io guardi altrove
oppure se vogliamo vedere cose ben più
importanti come da diversi anni ho
difficoltà motorie e a distanza di pochi
giorni
ritorno a vivere ho riassaporato la
gioia di camminare
capite bene che vivere in maniera quasi
viscerale personale tutte queste
esperienze tutte queste emozioni
positive o negative si trasforma quasi
in un'onda in un flusso che ci guida
volendo no verso l'opzione la scelta il
medico l'ospedale più adatta a noi è più
adatto a quel particolare momento siamo
riusciti a creare questo luogo questo
sito
questo social in grado veramente di
raccogliere questi frammenti di emozioni
di vita di persone di esperienze per
potervi dare a voi l'opportunità
l'opportunità di fare veramente o anche
a me una scelta consapevole e appurata
[Applauso]
[Musica]